this is a complete perversion of Justice
I I do remember reading that story now
that you mentioned it that evidence was
actually withheld I mean again these
people care nothing for rule of law they
don't care about the process they care
about the outcome the evidence that
Tucker showed of the Capitol Police
walking Jake I saw that yeah walking him
up the stairs and the door was locked
they found another door they opened up
the door they walked them to the floor
of the cabinet Coco he gave his prayer
thank you Lord God Almighty for the
United States Senate thank you for the
Capitol Police for keeping us safe and
then they walked him out and he went
home yep uh so again people could say
well he still broke the law by being
there but that really changes things a
little bit from The Narrative that they
showed at j6 well I mean it's hard to
say that somebody is a trespasser when
police officers literally walk them
through the building and tell them that
they can be there I mean I mean you
would have thought if he was doing
something illegal they would have
perhaps been the one to notice it yeah
it's kind of crazy I know that's a crazy
experience the police were in on the
insurrection